あずれ冊をです
あ
徹夜です
普通に多分大学生も皆
もう
年度が変わるかなぁ
それぞのテスト治安とかレポート中ですごい大変な好きだと思うんですよねー
なんで僕も今すぐも忙しくて tetsuya なんで今日は
僕のグッズを一つ聞いてください
最近ですねー
ぞ
すごい困ってるんですよ
今使っている壁があるんですけど新しい壁の買おうと思って
でも瀬文したんですよ1週間前につほどでもうそのカメラのための
この
プロテクターと
こうしている買ったんですけどまだ来ないんですよ
いい溶けるんですか言ってるんですか
雨水管立ってるんですよ発送いたしましたメールも来たし
きたしもうていいと思ってもまだ来ないんですよ
いつ来るんですか
も我慢できねぇ
すっごいナッツいいやつ買ったんで買ってからぬ
動画凄いだして良くなるねぇまったりくださいねん
それが来ないんですよ
a 溶けるんですかこの時に紹介しておくと
これです
nex 5 r です
泣いたり笑ってホッ
あのデジカメっぽい起きたんですけど
一眼レスって皆さんわかりますか分からないありがとうございます
なんか映画みたいなだスティックわかりますよわからないか
体型がも焼けるんですよ車体だけが凄い綺麗になって
背景が小屋てるっていう
入れないかなぁ
あこれこれこれ
こういう感じです
フォア
この院でだけがちょっと
普通かもだったのであった
レンズのプロジェクターだけあるっていうすごいです
なんかはせずない
ですよね
っていう時だけの僕の話られです
田畑プレースわかるんですよね
開封すると思うねー
混ぜてくださいねおやすみっ
ni